hi
my name is emil keiner i'm the product
manager for google cloud armor
on the network security product team at
google cloud today i'll be talking to
you about how to protect your
applications
from distributed denial service attacks
as well as targeted web attacks
using cloud armor we'll start off with
an overview of network security in
general on google cloud
from there we'll discuss all the latest
and greatest announcements
and new features that we've launched
with for cloud armor over the past
several months
after that we'll dive in and discuss
in depth how application protection in
ddos defense works
and then we'll discuss some customer use
cases about how to protect your
applications in real world scenarios
security follows a shared responsibility
model on google cloud
we work to secure our network and
infrastructure and provide customers the
tools necessary to do so in their own
projects
we enable and encourage customers to
follow a defense in-depth approach
and deploy security controls at various
levels of their
stack and infrastructure to enforce
access controls
and ensure data and mission-critical
workloads remain private and secure
on google cloud we have several key
network security controls
starting from the outside in we have
cloud armor the identity aware proxy and
the global load balancers as our layer 7
controls at the edge of the network
cloud armor in conjunction with the
global lbs protect applications from
ddos attacks
the identitywhere proxy is part of our
beyond corp line of products to allow
access to internal applications without
needing a vpn firewalls in red
apply at the vpc level and can be used
to customize access for north-south
traffic
as well as east-west traffic into out of
or through vpcs
firewalls are used to define vpc
boundaries but can be as granular as per
host
vpc service controls in blue can be used
to control access to and from
gcp services and managed apis such as
bigquery or cloud storage to or from the
internet
gcp vpcs or on-premise sources
in yellow we have packet mirroring that
allows you to deploy a tap
and mirror packets at the vm or
container cluster boundary to a
configurable collector destination
finally we also support sending outbound
traffic through cloudnat
as well as various interconnect and vpn
options to enhance privacy and security
cloud load balancing is a critical
component of the end to end network
security story
we have three flavors of global load
balancing the https load balancer
the ssl proxy and the tcp proxy the
first two load balancers are ssl
terminating
meaning you are able to offload the ssl
termination and decryption to our edge
proxies
and will handle enforcing ssl policies
upstream of your infrastructure
by uploading your certificates and
configuring custom ssl policies
you can ensure only pre-approved ssl tls
versions and ciphers are allowed on a
per-vip
basis all the global load balancers
employ a two-tier global based system
rather than a dna based load balancing
mechanism
we broadcast the load bouncer's ip
address globally
and end user requests are routed to and
terminated at the geographically nearest
point of presence or pop
to them from there the request is
coalexed and proxy
proxied over google's fiber backbone to
the customer back end in the
geographically nearest region
with available capacity at each stage of
the process
we optimize on latency taking into
account capacity
if the underlying application is
deployed across multiple regions
cloud armor is the web application
firewall and ddos mitigation service
able to provide layer 7 protection and
filtering for workloads deployed
on gcp on-prem or with other
infrastructure providers
cloud armor is deeply integrated with
the global load balancing
infrastructure and is able to inspect
and filter incoming requests
after the ssl termination has occurred
more specifically with cloud armor
customers are able to protect
their http fronted applications from
ddos attack
filter incoming requests by geography or
most l7 parameters like request headers
or cookies
moreover as a web application firewall
cloud armor contains pre-configured
rules to prevent against the most common
attacks
and vulnerability exploit attempts users
have access to real-time telemetry in
the form of logs
sent to cloud logging containing
cloudara's decisions on a per request
basis
a monitoring dashboard that gives
granular views of allowed
denied or preview traffic as well as a
correlated wife security findings that
are sent to the cloud security command
center
as of march of this year a rich set of
waft capabilities for cloud armor was
made generally available
pre-configured rules can help mitigate
the os top 10 risks
we have ported over the mod security
core rule set introducing
rules to detect and block sql injection
and cross-site scripting attempts
as generally available additionally
rules for local file inclusion
remote file inclusion and remote code
execution
are available as beta the rest of the
core rule set is targeted for
release over the course of this year
with geo-based rules customers can
enforce
access controls based on the source
geography of each request
the ipgo mappings are sourced from
google's own
geo team so you can be sure of its
accuracy
we've also launched an extensible rules
language that allows users to configure
custom layer 7 filtering policies across
request headers request parameters and
cookies
finally cloud armor is now integrated
with the security command center
with cloud armor findings as well as
assets being sent to the csac dashboard
to alert defenders of potential attacks
against protected applications or
websites
we have recently greatly increased the
flexibility of cloud armor
deployments to protect an expanded set
of customer infrastructure on gcp
as well as in hybrid use cases located
on-prem or in other cloud providers
cloud armor now supports protecting
cloud cdn of origin servers
by enforcing security policies on
dynamic requests
as well as cache misses destined for the
cdn origin server
customer applications are often complex
serving both cacheable static content
as well as dynamic requests from the
same services
with cloud armor able to inspect and
filter requests
destined to cdn origin servers users can
now
mitigate computationally expensive cash
busting attacks
as well as help protect dynamic portions
of websites and applications from os top
10 risks
enterprises often need to enforce a
consistent set of security controls
for their applications no matter where
they are deployed
whether they are migrating to gcp or
running in permanently hybrid
configurations
we recently launched support for
internet network endpoint groups that
allows customers to leverage
all of google's edge infrastructure
including cloud load balancers cloud cdn
and cloud armor to protect their website
or application no matter where they are
hosted
now google can help protect your
applications
whether from ddos attacks or other
common web attacks without
having to deploy the application
directly on gcp
finally gke ingress support for cloud
armor has recently reached general
availability
gke users can help protect their
containerized workloads by placing them
behind
the cloud load balancers and configuring
a cloud armor security policy for layer
seven filtering and waff use cases
also we are proud to announce the
availability as a beta
a highly requested capability to allow
or deny traffic through a cloud armor
security policy
based on a pre-configured named ip list
many of our customers have received
traffic into their gcp projects from
upstream service providers
such as other cdns prior to this
capability customers would have to
self-manage
the list of ips from upstream providers
to ensure they can receive those
requests through a cloud armor security
policy
now customers can configure a security
policy to deny all traffic
from the internet by default and allow
only traffic from desired
ip ranges by referencing the named ip
lists
for now the named ip lists are global in
nature and not user defined
we are launching the beta with three
launch partners fastly cloudflare and
imperva
but intend to add the other service
providers over time
finally we are excited and proud to
announce the beta launch
of cloud armor managed protection a set
of ddos mitigation and wax services
offered at two service tiers standard
and plus
which bundles together all the features
and capabilities of cloud armor with
additional value-added services all for
an enterprise friendly
predictable monthly subscription last
month we published a blog post
announcing that google had successfully
detected
and mitigated the largest ddos attack
ever reported to date
now with managed protection google cloud
customers can leverage
the same edge capacity as well as ddos
defense expertise to protect their own
applications
and other publicly exposed workloads
with a subscription plan that
offers enterprise friendly and
critically predictable pricing
which is not driven by incoming request
volumes
cloud armor lap usage includes rules
policies and requests are included in
the subscription plan
meaning cloud armor monthly price will
remain relatively fixed even if you are
targeted
by a high volume layer 7ddos attack that
needs to be mitigated by cloud armor
over time we will expand the services
offered in the plus tier
starting with the upcoming google
curated rule sets like the named ip
lists announced
previously for more information on
managed protection please refer to the
cloud armor blog announcing the beta
as well as the product page for a sign
up form to get more information
on gcp customers enjoy an unrivaled
level of ddos protection from a wide
variety of attack types
it is important to understand that ddos
protection cloud customers are able to
receive
is the same that has been developed over
the past 20 years to protect and ensure
availability of google's own services
thanks to the global nature of google's
network we are able to absorb
and dissipate or otherwise mitigate
layer 3 and layer 4
network or volumetric attacks across
various components in our global load
balancing infrastructure
the way this automatic mitigation works
is that all three types of global load
balancers will
only proxy requests back to the customer
back-end service
with that when that request has
completed a three-way tcp
handshake for volumetric and protocol
based
ddos attacks like udp amplification or
reflection
as well as tcp floods the dcp the tcp
handshake
is actually never established so we can
safely drop this unwelcome traffic far
upstream of your infrastructure
this happens automatically in upstream
of customer infrastructure
next cloud armor security policies can
be configured and attached to the
load-balanced back-end services
to further provide layer 7 application
layer protection and access controls
cloud armor security policies can be
configured to limit access based on
source ip or geo
a pre-configured waf rule set as well as
our fully customizable rules language to
craft
custom layer 7 filtering policies
diving in a bit further cloud armor
security policies
can simultaneously invoke pre-configured
waf
rules as well as user-defined rules to
inspect request headers parameters and
cookies
policies are stored evaluated and
enforced at the edge of google's network
far upstream of customers infrastructure
in the example on this slide we have a
policy that first denies access to any
external
clients requesting access to the admin
portal of our example application
next the cloud armor security policy is
configured to invoke pre-configured waf
rules to detect and block known
signatures for sql injection
and cross-site scripting attacks which
collectively have dozens of
sub-signatures under the hood
finally if the request is neither
targeting the admin portal nor
containing a sql injection or cross-site
scripting signature
we will allow that traffic as configured
through the default rule
now we'll discuss some example use cases
for how customers can protect their
applications
in order to protect your application
from volumetric and protocol based ddos
attacks
all that is necessary is to deploy one
of the global load balancers in front of
your http or tcp workload
once fronted by the load balancers cloud
armor in conjunction with the lbs will
automatically mitigate ddos attacks like
dns amplification attacks
syn floods and other common layer 3
layer 4 ddos attacks
the only requests that will be proxied
back to your applications are ones that
have completed
the three-way handshake and are
well-formed layer 7 requests
to add layer 7 protection for your
applications the first thing you need to
do is configure a cloud armor security
policy and attach it to the back-end
service that is hosting the application
or workload to be protected
cloud armor security policies are used
to customize access to protected
resources
there is a one-to-many relationship
between policies and back ends meaning
one policy
can be attached to multiple backend
services but each backend can only have
one security policy protecting it
each policy consists of a prioritized
list of rules as well as a default rule
as an incoming request tries to reach
the customer back end service
claude armor will evaluate each rule in
priority order against the traffic
the first matching rule will win meaning
it will dictate the action
to take allow or deny in this case
if the traffic doesn't match any rules
then the action configured with the
default rule will be applied
to either allow or deny the traffic
through to the
targeted back end
visibility and telemetry is key for any
comprehensive application protection
solution
cloud armor exposes this information in
near real time across several telemetry
platforms at google cloud
per request logs are captured and sent
to cloud logging containing all
decisions that cloud armor makes with
regard to layer 7 requests
as well as which rules fired and why
real time telemetry for request volumes
is available at various levels of
granularity
through cloud monitoring in our
pre-configured dashboard
to help you visualize and build alerting
policies against
changes in traffic patterns finally
correlated security findings about
unexpected traffic spikes are sent to
the security command center
to trigger investigation and possibly
incident response workflows
putting it all together here is an
example of a sophisticated use cases
that leverages the ability to
dynamically update cloud armor security
policies through our feature-rich rest
api
or cli here we see an application
fronted by a cloud load balancer with
google cloud armor enabled telemetry is
collected into a monitoring and
analytics
workflow either homegrown by the
customer commercial off the shelf
or using gcp's native data analytics
tools such as bigquery
other sources of telemetry and logging
are added to the system
including from the application from
cloud armor and other devices on the
network
next threat or fraud detection
algorithms will correlate the various
telemetry
and generate additional signatures of
malicious malicious traffic to block
upstream
these signatures can then be dynamically
pushed into the cloud armor security
policy
as a new rule to quickly block the newly
detected malicious behavior
all at the edge of google's network
with that i wanted to thank you for
joining me today if you have any other
questions please check out our recently
published blogs or the product page
and don't hesitate to reach out with any
detailed questions and we'd be happy to
follow up with you
thank you